you know the world can be a bleak place
and getting Bleaker by the day which is
why it's all the more important to
celebrate the good news when it comes
rejoice in the victories which brings us
to this past weekend and the opening of
the latest installment in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe a phrase that I
prefer not to use because the universe
itself is vast and varied and
fascinating but the Marvel Universe on
the other hand is repetitive and dull
and tedious and pointless not really a
universe at all it turns out it's just a
series of films where each film exists
only to set up the next film which
exists to set up the next one and the
whole thing altogether primarily exists
to sell merchandise um the only
similarity between the actual universe
and the Marvel universe is that the
actual Universe has lots of black holes
and the Marvel universe is a black hole
it is a giant gaping vacuum that has
expanded by consuming the rest of the
movie industry so that at this point in
2023 nobody in the movie industry knows
how to make a movie unless it involves
people in rubber suits kicking each each
other all that to say the latest Marvel
movie creatively titled the Marvels was
a massive humiliating flop and thank God
for that we should also note as this is
likely not a coincidental factor that
the film is a female Le girl powerfest
starring a team of women superheroes
headlined by feminist actor Brie Larsson
the abysmal numbers show just how
thoroughly uninterested audiences seem
to be in this kind of content um the
Marvel's opened with a $47 million
weekend which is a number that
you know might seem high given that $47
million would be enough to feed 9,000
African villages for 100 years or
something but in terms of Marvel movies
it is a catastrophic failure easily the
worst opening weekend in the history of
the of of the Marvel franchise generally
and made all the worse when you compare
the box office receipts to the
production budget reportedly the Marvels
cost something like 275 million doll to
make and that's just the production
budget of the film it doesn't count the
many millions spent on marketing
yet just to recover the production
budget the Marvels would would have to
earn somewhere just south of half a
billion dollars at a minimum and based
on the opening performance it is
extremely unlikely that that will happen
the film is doomed to go down as yet
another recent big budget Hollywood flop
flop in fact the performance has been so
bad that according to the Hollywood
Reporter it has Marvel Studios
rethinking their whole strategy for for
um making and releasing films watch this
isn't the first warning sign that
something's been a Miss within Marvel in
terms of quality control as Kevin
feige's team has been in overdrive
producing shows for streaming features
eternals and Ant-Man in the WASP quantam
Mania also received B cinema scores
while audiences began complaining about
keeping up with an increasing number of
shows on Disney plus to understand the
overarching MCU story behind the scenes
Marvel Studios and Disney were well
aware the Marvel's was in trouble before
it hit the big screen sources tell The
Hollywood Reporter there was also a
recognition that fig anda's team needed
time to take stock of their theatrical
tent poles on November 8th Bob Iger said
on an earnings call that Disney's movie
empire is quote lost Focus because of an
emphasis on quantity over quality in the
rush to feed Disney plus under the Bob
Chek regime though it was Iger himself
who initiated this push before Chex
Reign sources say feige and his team
felt this mandate keenly to the
detriment of Marvel's movies the next
day Marvel and Disney revealed they were
scaling back the number of superhero
films they will release in 2024 from 3
to just
one well if I could offer some solist
audiences you don't need to keep track
of the overarching Marvel story because
there is no story you're watching a
series of extended toy commercials and
the narrative is very much a secondary
concern if it ranks even that high which
I don't think it does but this leads to
the question of why a redundant lifeless
big budget but weirdly cheap looking
feminist superhero girl Power movie
would perform so poorly now that's not a
question that any sane person has to
think very hard to answer um you know
you know I I just kind of answered it in
the question itself the question answers
itself the media isn't thinking very
hard either they've of course decided
that it must be sexism so here's an
article in The Stylist laying the
groundwork for this excuse before the
box office receipts were tallied that's
how you know right that a movie is good
is that before it comes out they're
already telling you that if you don't
watch it you're a bigot um quote fresh
off the back of first reviews fake takes
about the film have sadly started to
circulate on X for Twitter from people
who have not yet seen the movie this
might sound familiar the first trailer
stirred the sexist trolls from their
Slumber and after they review bombed
Captain Marvel it was almost inevitable
they would return to do the same for the
sequel within two days of its release
the teaser became the most disliked
video on YouTube with one user lab
labeling it Captain feminist and the
patriarchy Stone which is great uh it
seems that the toxic underbelly of the
comic book franchise is back on display
as some misogynistic fans attempt to
slander
a brilliant film simply because it's led
by three
women
slander yes the toxic underbelly is
slandering again got to watch out for
that toxic
underbelly and of course this has to be
the explanation why else would would
wouldn't people flock to see a movie
where a bunch of annoying women run
around punching people that's the
conclusion shared by the director of the
film too Nia dasta as Breitbart reports
she was making these kinds of excuses
well ahead of time quote as Disney's the
Marvel goes down as the biggest flop in
Marvel Cinematic univers Universe
history the movie's director niia dasta
has played her final three cards race
gender and sexuality the Marvel's
director lashed out at haters calling
them bigots in a recent interview with
variety But the irony is that her
movie's largest group of ticket buyers
has turned out to be male and white NE
the Costa sounded off on the negative
fan buildup uh to the Marvels during the
interview quote there are Pockets where
you go because you're like I'm a a super
fan I want to exist in the space of just
adoration which includes civilized
critique then there are Pockets that are
really virulent and violent and racist
and sexist and homophobic and all those
awful things and I choose the side of
light that's the part of fandom I'm
attracted
to um so did you catch that it is not
only racist and somehow homophobic to
dislike the Marvels it is also violent
not paying 30 bucks for two tickets to
the Marvels this weekend is an act of
violence choose the side of light the
director implores you choose goodness
Choose Love choose to give her your
money since the overturning of roie Wade
the left has lost their minds left
leftism is their religion abortion is
their official Sacrament meanwhile prif
efforts which are now more important
than ever are booming despite the
narrative Pro lifers have not gone away
in fact they're getting more and more
active as one of the largest prif
organizations in the world no one is in
a better position than 40 Days for life
to end abortion state byst state they've
opened a record number of locations
since row was overturned they continue
to grow in volunteers they now have 1
million Volunteers in 1500 cities 40
Days for life holds peaceful visuals
outside abortion facilities in an effort
to change hearts and Minds in the most
blue pro-abortion States you can help 40
Days for Life fight ongoing legal
battles to protect free speech for their
volunteers by giving a tax deductible
gift of any amount at 40 days
forlife.com that's 40 days forlife.com
in a world filled with uncertainties you
need to be prepared for any possibility
you need my Patriot Supply my Patriot
Supply is your trusted partner for
emergency preparedness whether it's a
natural disaster a sudden emergency or
unforeseen circumstances my Patriot
supplies highquality food storage
solutions ensure that you and your loved
ones are always wellfed no matter what
comes your way their bestselling
three-month emergency food kit is even
customizable with options like their
ultimate breakfast kit a mega protein
kit with real meat and even a
gluten-free kit your 3-month emergency
food supply provides over 2,000 calories
each day for optimal strength and energy
in stressful situations don't wait for
disaster to strike before taking action
invest in your safety and well-being by
securing your food storage today go to
prepare withth walsh.com to get your
three-month food supply today that's
prepare
withthomas one of the dozens of problems
anyway is that as it said in the article
by far the largest demo who went to see
the film were men and most of them were
white men presumably blind and deaf
white men but those details aren't
recorded so perhaps NE Casta needs to
take this take this up with all the
women and racial minorities who
arrogantly and violently declined to go
see the movie in theaters I mean they're
the ones who failed her or maybe
alternatively she is the one who failed
by failing to make a movie that anyone
wants to see yes now I think maybe we're
on to something here so why did the
movie actually flop I think there are
two reasons both both of which we've
already alluded to um uh the first is
that for the most part the truth is
nobody really wants to see female Le
action movies people are not that
interested in female action Stars
Hollywood insists that we should be
interested but we just aren't female
audiences are it turns out especially
not interested in female action stars
now there are some exceptions to this
rule there are a few iconic female
action her like soury Weaver as Ripley
in in in the Alien films and a couple of
others but as a general principle action
movies are a man's domain they are for
men they are about men and that's just
the real you could you could be sad
about it you can insist that it should
be different but it is what it is and
that's why if you look at a list of the
top 50 highest grossing action films of
all time maybe two of the top 50 were
led by women and one of them was Captain
Marvel coming com in at 19 on the list
which which gross about a billion
dollars but that film was sandwiched in
between Avengers endgame and Avengers
Infinity War both in the top five and it
rode their coattails to box office Glory
so Captain Marvel is kind of like the
WNBA of superh Heroes her existence
depends on the success of her male
counterparts although In fairness people
did actually go to see Captain Marvel
but literally nobody in history has ever
seen a WNBA game in any case the point
is that audience audiences aren't
generally interested in female action
films it's not because of sexism given
that female audiences are also
uninterested it's it's more that men by
and large just they make more compelling
more convincing more entertaining action
heroes that's not my opinion I mean it
is my opinion but it's not just my
opinion all of the objective evidence
suggests that it is the opinion of
almost all movie goers men and women
alike whether they put it so bluntly or
not also the audience for movies is
primarily male especially superheroes so
like when an 8-year-old boy goes to see
Spider-Man he likes to imagine himself
as the hero no 8-year-old boy is running
around the house with a bath towel made
into a cape shouting I'm Captain Marvel
that's not happening Hollywood has tried
to turn the action genre into a women a
woman's
domain uh they've tried to feminize it
like they tried to feminize everything
but the social engineering just hasn't
taken a hold and probably never will and
second as I've already covered female
letter or not the superhero genre is is
is uh it has long sense grown stale now
it is moldy and decomposing on the
counter there is just a limit right to
how long you can convince the audience
to come back and watch the same story
over and over again it turns out that
the limit is about 20 years that's the
limit now for me it was like 20 minutes
I saw 20 minutes of of one superhero
movie I said yeah I kind of get it like
I guess it's fine I get it I understand
I understand superhero movies I
understand what you're doing I get it I
don't need to rewatch it a million times
I don't to spend two decades of my life
watching this same thing over and over
and over again but a lot of audiences
apparently they needed to do that and
but even those audiences are are uh the
ones that have a a much greater
tolerance for repetition even though
even they have grown tired of
it uh I would say that their tolerance
for repetition is too great but at least
now most of them seem to agree that if
Marvel wants us to watch their movies
they need to start making actual movies
rather than as Martin Scorsese would say
amusement park rides that go around in
circles forever never ending never
saying anything never bothering to tell
a
story or they can keep on their current
track and continue losing money which is
perfectly fine with
me either way it's not just me saying
but all of America apparently saying
that the Marvels is today
cancelled hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there